hey guys it's justine and today we've
got a new insta360 go to
this is a follow-up to the first version
and what i love
so much about this camera is it's kind
of like a first-person
view camera like you can wear it on your
shirt you can place it places that you
normally could not
put any other types of cameras i had so
much fun with the first version
it actually captured a fall while the
camera had a fall i didn't fall
but i dropped it so far when i was
hiking up the side of this mountain
and it captured it not really sure where
i'm gonna be taking this but i do plan
on going
on a very nice coveted safe adventure do
i call it covent say
what is like is there like a proper term
for like now while i might not be going
to hawaii i am doing a really fun road
trip with my friends
and i'm super excited i can't see
friends because i can't have friends
because that's not cope it's safe we're
all in the same quarantine bubble this
is a dilemma
so let's unbox this get it all set up
and then i'm heading out on a road trip
which i'm very excited about being able
to test this out out on the road because
being able to get those really cool fpv
shots
is a really fun added perspective
[Music]
so this has the flow state stabilization
you can mount it anywhere because it is
magnetic which is awesome
1440p 50 frames a second you can do
hyper lapses you can do wi-fi previews
connected to your phone oh look at you
oh you're so
you're so cute it's so small like look
at this
it's like this is like i can swallow
this don't swallow it but i could
i mean that's small like it's smaller
than the chapstick
like half the size of a sony battery
look at it in comparison to this knife
which it can stick on to because it's
magnetic
oh okay this is neat this is a little
necklace that you can wear so this
allows you to kind of just
go like that
it's really cool here's the rest of the
accessories so this is the little case
that you can store it in this also
doubles as a charger
whoa whoa this is so neat this is way
cooler than the last version
can i remote record can oh
you can so you can use this as a remote
and it connects
so i can start recording with the case
when i unboxed this first version of
this
the thing that i said was how excited i
was for the next version i mean i was
actually opening the first version i was
like the next one
is gonna be incredible the first one was
awesome but this has basically taken
everything that we learned from that
first one and turned it into
look at this it's got like a little
tripod
hole can you
can you just look i'm so into those
there's a mount right here so if you
wanted to use a larger tripod you could
also powered by usbc is this a little
cradle
is this a little bed for you to take a
little nap in
it has a little hammock it's a clip
look at that
what's this a pivot stand
i'm learning as i open it look at that
you're cute so here's everything that
comes in the box you have your magnetic
necklace you've got the camera you've
got this little pivot stand you've got
your little hammock that is actually a
clip
your usb cable and this super cool case
that charges
it also doubles as a tripod i love the
fact that they've decided to integrate a
remote into this
which will let you easily control this
with a little display on it so
that's pretty neat let's connect it to
my phone do a firmware upgrade
and get outside or inside i don't know
where i don't know what's gonna happen
next
[Music]
hi we're doing some lightsaber training
today totally normal morning
totally normal totally normal
[Music]
[Applause]
i'm scared
[Music]
my lightsaber stopped working i think
i've dropped it one too many times
i think it's dead
[Music]
hey jen you ready for this run are you
ready
maybe
[Music]
looks like we're coming up upon an
obstacle
potentially hard to say
oh that's magnetic that's what i said
you didn't see the pool uh
it's we got to turn around but there's a
yoda statue of liberty over there which
is pretty incredible what i love about
this is it is magnetic so if there's
like a magnet around i could just like
stick it on something
and then i just stick it back to my
little necklace
right here and then i just take it
put it back on and we're ready to go
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
you